qué pensaría usted si fotografías suyas
hacen parte de un banco de millones de
imágenes que están dentro de un programa
de vigilancia Pues bien el software
Clear View basado en Nueva York afirma
que planea recolectar 100 mil millones
de imágenes de páginas como Facebook
Instagram Google o YouTube esto equivale
a tener entre 13 y 14 fotografías de
cada persona que hay en el planeta la
polémica está en que ninguna de estas
fotos fueron adquiridas con el
consentimiento de las personas que están
en ellas
vende las bases de datos a diferentes
instituciones alrededor del mundo y
afirma que es para perseguir al crimen
actualmente es el segundo sistema más
preciso de reconocimiento facial después
del programa de vigilancia de China
Aunque la violación a la privacidad es
un tema sobre la mesa al punto que Clear
ha sido limitada en diferentes países
como Francia Italia y Estados Unidos los
periodistas de nuestra cadena hermana en
francés
hijo mío investigaron más sobre este
programa esto es reporteros Plus
[Música]
y aquí
el reconocimiento facial es el futuro
es como todo el resto de la tecnología
nos facilita el trabajo
cuando yo llegué no teníamos cámaras
corporales Ahora sí tampoco teníamos un
centro para detectar la delincuencia en
tiempo real Ahora son nuestras cámaras
de vigilancia en la ciudad antes si
nadie veía nada si nadie sabía nada era
imposible obtener la descripción de un
vehículo o de la persona que estuviera
cometiendo el crimen
[Música]
me gusta llamarlo el centro neurálgico
del departamento de policía
desde aquí monitoreamos nuestras cámaras
de seguridad pública tenemos
reconocimiento facial lectura de
matrículas todo lo que puede ayudar a
nuestros agentes a hacer su trabajo
en este momento tenemos
575 cámaras y ese número sigue
aumentando
la cámara que van a ver ahora está en lo
alto del Hotel intercontinental Ahora
quiero que vean hasta donde se puede
hacer zoom
y miren aquí justo al lado de una tienda
están vendiendo drogas como si fueran
dulces narcóticos
al acercarnos con nuestra cámara podemos
ver todo lo que está pasando se ven las
bolsitas se pueden ver que están
vendiendo sabe captamos tantas cosas
[Música]
ayer robaron un auto el delincuente que
cometió el robo atropelló al propietario
del vehículo huyó de la escena y la
víctima murió en el lugar
debería estar entre los archivos del
Real Time Frank Center
a este es el asesinato de ayer no sabía
que la habíamos identificado con Clear
por Inteligencia artificial un programa
que permite identificar a una persona
casi al instante a partir de una foto lo
hace gracias a una búsqueda en una base
de datos compuesta por miles de millones
de imágenes es un reconocimiento facial
muy sencillo tomamos una foto la
cargamos en el ordenador y el sistema
nos arroja coincidencias similares a esa
foto una identificación en la que
podríamos tardar semanas con el
reconocimiento facial podemos
encontrarla en cuestión de minutos o
días porque quizás la foto está en las
redes sociales
Facebook Twitter Instagram una parte de
las imágenes de ella y proviene de las
redes sociales para los agentes es una
mina de información sobre los
sospechosos sus Cómplices y sus círculos
cercanos
es el segundo sistema de reconocimiento
facial más preciso del mundo el primero
es un sistema del partido comunista
chino pero ese no lo queremos utilizar
en China el reconocimiento facial se
utiliza para la vigilancia masiva
hay cámaras por todas partes
los habitantes son identificados en
tiempo real seguidos paso a paso y hasta
son valorados por la Inteligencia
artificial
los policías de Miami afirman hacer un
uso responsable de
sin aplicar el reconocimiento facial en
tiempo real se limitarían a identificar
a los sospechosos después de los
incidentes comparando las imágenes de
las cámaras de vigilancia con la
gigantesca base de datos de Clear View
para tener acceso al sistema el
departamento de policía de Miami paga
una suscripción de 47 mil dólares al año
en Estados Unidos casi no existen leyes
que regulen el uso que la policía puede
hacer del reconocimiento facial
surgió de una empresa fundada en 2017 en
Nueva York llamada Smart
en unos años se convirtió en la empresa
de reconocimiento facial más
controvertida del mundo
en su sitio web
Afirma tener una base de datos con más
de 20 mil millones de imágenes la mayor
galería de rostros del mundo tiene
clientes destacados como las agencias
estadounidenses del orden público y su
misión es de interés general combatir el
crimen
incluso ha participado en la guerra en
Ucrania desde el comienzo del conflicto
el uso exacto de esta herramienta no es
claro las fuerzas se quiefla estarían
utilizando para detectar a Los espías
rusos además de otras tareas
hubo un problema con los soldados rusos
vestidos con uniformes ucranianos
Entonces ahora los ucranianos sacan su
teléfono los escanean con la cámara y
dicen no usted Yuri de Lugo usted
Dimitri vladivostok saben Quiénes son
gracias al reconocimiento facial y a la
Inteligencia artificial
Richard Clark sabe de lo que habla y su
parte de su carrera en la casa blanca
era el encargado de la lucha contra el
terrorismo Clark estuvo en primera línea
Durante los atentados del 11 de
septiembre ante se pasara a trabajar en
el sector privado una de mis tareas en
el consejo asesor es asegurarme de que
no se haga nada poco ético o inmoral y
somos muy buenos en eso no le vendemos a
ciertos países no permitiremos que se
utilice para cualquier propósito
hongton el fundador y director general
de Clear View es un informático
australiano dice ser descendiente de la
realeza vietnamita y haber emigrado con
19 años a Estados Unidos
actualmente vive en Nueva York
siempre me ha encantado la programación
desde que era niño me quedaba en casa
después de la escuela para conectarme a
internet y Ver videos de profesores de
emaid dando clases de programación
terminé mudándome a silicon Valley
cuando era joven lo llamo el Hollywood
de los fanáticos de la informática todos
los mejores programadores quieren ir ahí
vamos a hacer una prueba con su cara
está bien sonría
conocimos a home en el verano de 2021
está buscando entre todas estas fotos en
línea
De dónde viene esa foto esta de aquí se
da desde es una foto grupal de Instagram
es increíble
nunca había visto esta foto
según su Creador El Secreto del sistema
es que está entrenado con miles de
fotografías
funciona con una red neuronal es un tipo
de Inteligencia artificial que está
entrenada con millones de rostros los
algoritmos anteriores medían la
distancia entre los ojos la nariz y la
boca pero una red neuronal está
entrenada con tantos tipos de fotos
distintos que se vuelve muy resistente
al cambio entonces las personas pueden
subir fotos desde distintos ángulos con
distintos tipos de luz y edades
diferentes a veces con gafas o con barba
la red Busca cualquier cosa pública
disponible en internet pueden ser sitios
web judiciales redes sociales cualquier
cosa que sea de libre acceso o que haya
sido publicada no hay nada privado
recopilar fotos de acceso público en
internet no es ilegal en Estados Unidos
Durante los primeros años Clear operó en
secreto hasta que un especialista en
tecnología reveló su existencia Mi
nombre es Freddy Martínez soy
investigador del project oncovers
overside hago mucha investigación en
particular sobre las tecnologías de
vigilancia policial y cómo se utilizan
como parte del proyecto empecé a
solicitar muchos documentos públicos
relacionados con tecnología de
reconocimiento facial así fue como
descubrir la existencia del creador el
derecho estadounidense permite que los
ciudadanos tengan acceso a los
documentos públicos Freddy obtuvo una
copia de las conversaciones entre
distintos departamentos de policía un
texto en particular llamó su atención
este documento fue redactado por los
abogados de básicamente Establece que el
público no tiene derecho a sus imágenes
y que la empresa Sencillamente puede
recopilarlas y venderlas de alguna
manera lo que están haciendo es crear
con el tiempo de expedientes de las
personas en línea fue en ese momento
cuando contactamos al New York Times y
esa fue la base para su historia en
enero de 2020 el New York Times reveló
la existencia de Clear viey y de su
directorio fotográfico mundial ninguna
otra empresa en Estados Unidos que yo
conozca se ha atrevido a hacer lo que ha
hecho Clear View porque es muy
controversial y muy abusivo buscar en
internet miles de millones de fotos de
personas entre las redes sociales los
sitios web de noticias locales los
empleadores de la gente en cualquier
parte y juntarlas en una base de datos
gigantesca de reconocimiento facial
esa base de datos se crea sin que nadie
sepa que su cara está incluida ahí se
hace sin el consentimiento de las
personas en nombre el derecho a la vida
privada la unión estadounidense por las
libertades civiles llevó a Clark ante
los tribunales de Illinois por violar la
ley de privacidad biométrica del Estado
salió en todos los medios
estadounidenses para defender su
aplicación
rápidamente el caso
se volvió mundial
fue objeto de otro escándalo cuando Lico
Bryant publicó un reportaje en el
huffington post en el que revelaba que
la empresa tenía vínculos con la extrema
derecha
para remontarnos hasta los inicios
nos encontramos con el inversionista
Charles Johnson También conocido como
San José
Afirma haber jugado un papel clave en
los inicios de la empresa en esa época
era amigo suyo pero en marzo de 2023
chat demandó a por incumplimiento de
contrato
[Música]
Charles Johnson es un aficionado de la
biométrica sus críticos consideran que
es un provocador de extrema derecha en
2015 después se publicaron una serie de
trinos racistas fue suspendido de
Twitter
con 33 años
y conoce a mucha gente
[Música]
particularmente en el ala derecha del
partido republicano aquí aparece en una
fotografía de 2016 con Steve banon el
asesor y jefe de campaña de Donald Trump
[Música]
durante años Chuck escribió artículos
para bridgver news un medio de derecha
extrema dirigido por balon
Chuck afirma que ahora está al margen de
Pero todavía tiene ideas para la empresa
según él la aplicación podría
interesarle al mercado europeo
ustedes también tienen el mismo problema
no todos esos migrantes y esas personas
que vienen de Siria llegarán más no
pueden ir todos a Francia o Alemania o a
Estados Unidos
habrá que encontrar una solución para
ese problema creo que el reconocimiento
facial puede ayudar con eso en 2017
publicó en Facebook que estaba creando
algoritmos para que los escuadrones de
deportación pudieran identificar a los
inmigrantes irregulares muchos tienen
iphones no están tan necesitados quiero
decir son pobres En comparación con
otras personas y tienen identidades así
se podría verificar Quién es quién
es una figura muy amenazante muy
virulenta y lo hace en parte para
hacerlo más aterrador y amenazante
posible en particular para las personas
que considera inferiores como las
mujeres personas afro personas con
descendencia judía
cualquiera que no sea un hombre blanco
heterosexual
[Música]
trabajé con shock durante cuatro años y
medio
constantemente Estaba tratando de
impresionar a la gente
demostrando que era poderoso y que
conocía personas poderosas
esta mujer pertenecía a la extrema
derecha frecuentó los círculos de
supremacistas blancos y conoce sus
secretos
actualmente vives escondida por razones
de seguridad la llamaremos Artemisa
debo Mostrar mi identidad porque recibí
muchas amenazas
Cuando empecé a alejarme de la extrema
derecha
[Música]
[Aplausos]
Artemisa conoció a los principales ciber
militantes del extremo derecha los
escribe como personajes peligrosos que
bajo el escudo del humor negro predican
el odio en línea
cuando la gente les dice algo actúan
como si no fuera grave
hay que estar muy atento al tratar con
ellos
como el de Pepe la rana
dicen Hello amigos tienen muchas
expresiones raras pero mientras tanto
están hablando de exterminar a los
judíos
todas esas personas tienen el mismo
discurso racista de antes el de la
supremacía blanca de 1920
y lo combinan con el nuevo terrorismo de
internet de extrema derecha
no sé qué hizo shock para tener tanto
dinero
sé que tiene conexiones con
multimillonarios poderosos
Chuck Afirma Haber puesto sus contactos
a disposición de hongton that el
director de Clear viey para encontrar a
los primeros inversionistas
yo le presenté muchos de mis contactos a
Juan básicamente todos pensaban que era
un ingeniero muy brillante pero que no
era un hombre de negocios y yo le dije
no te preocupes yo me encargo de esa
parte conseguimos mucho dinero para
Nuestra Empresa y empezó a prosperar fue
una época muy exitosa
nació y se desarrolló Durante los años
Trump Cleveland verano de 2016 Donald
Trump ganó las primarias del partido
republicano Chuck Johnson y hongton that
estaban entre sus partidarios
el multimillonario Peter Field se
convertiría en uno de los primeros
inversionistas deway
en Facebook
[Música]
[Aplausos]
dice que fue increíble donde conoció a
hongton y a peter Field
One realmente quería conocer a peter
quería hablar con él y como yo lo
conocía le dije Vamos a organizarlo le
dije que One estaba trabajando en cosas
interesantes como el reconocimiento
facial y esas cosas y a peter le llamó
mucho la atención hablamos mucho Sobre
corrección política y comunismo
[Aplausos]
es uno de los fundadores de PayPal junto
con elon musk en los años 1990 creó ese
sistema de pago que todos conocemos
conocimos la carrera de elon pero
peterfield es mucho más discreto con los
atentados el 11 de septiembre la carrera
de Peter Field se perfiló Estados Unidos
quedó traumatizada Y puso en marcha un
programa de espionaje mundial fue el
comienzo de la guerra contra el
terrorismo ya nada se le escaparía las
antenas de la nsa la agencia de
espionaje digital
Peter Field fundó entonces palantir un
poderoso software de tratamiento y
análisis de datos los primeros clientes
de palantir fueron las agencias de
inteligencia estadounidenses
[Música]
palantir se fundó porque la agencia
nacional de seguridad lanzó un programa
de vigilancia masiva gigantesco en todos
los rincones del planeta El problema es
que eso produjo una cantidad astronómica
de datos y para darle un sentido a todos
esos datos se necesitaba un nuevo tipo
de programa que sería palantir
palantir es el gran hermano cuando le
propusieron invertir en el
reconocimiento facial
el jefe de palantir aceptó para
una empresa muy atractiva encaja
perfectamente en ese ecosistema de la
industria de la vigilancia más eficaz
del planeta
peterfield Encarna el ala derecha de
silicon Bailey
real en esta corriente autoritaria los
algoritmos están por encima de la
democracia
en 2009 escribió en un artículo
la gran visión sobre la gobernanza es
que los humanos son en realidad un
rebaño de ovejas que debe ser guiado por
perros
es una sociedad en la que los perros
pastores están en lo alto de la pirámide
para poder controlar a las ovejas esa es
a grandes rasgos su visión de la
sociedad
a finales de 2016 Donald Trump fue
elegido presidente
para muchos de nosotros se sintió como
nuestro propio woodstock
despegó pero hasta 2020 estuvo bajo los
radares
[Música]
en Europa a diferencia de Estados Unidos
el reconocimiento facial está
estrictamente regulado
Pero estos transeúntes no están a salvo
ellos no lo saben pero sus caras podrían
estar en la base de datos de Claire View
la primera vez que supe de Clear View
fue en enero del 2020 en un artículo del
New York Times
y me interesó mucho porque era la
primera vez que voy a hablar de una
empresa que hacía reconocimiento facial
con su propia base de datos
yo evilén fue la primera francesa en
encender las alarmas para crear su base
de datos Clear viey diseñó algoritmos
capaces de aspirar diariamente millones
de fotos en internet
una práctica controvertida llamada
scrapping
el scripping Es una herramienta
automática que es el lanzan todos los
sitios web del mundo y permite recopilar
fotos a gran escala
todas las fotos que ustedes hayan
publicado en sus perfiles de Facebook en
Twitter en instagram ellos las han
tomado y las han guardado
puede que después ustedes hayan borrado
las fotos de sus cuentas Pero ellos ya
tienen una copia hicieron eso pero a una
escala masiva
Fue entonces cuando empecé a preguntarme
yo también tenía datos personales y
fotos de los franceses o incluso de los
europeos
el derecho europeo permite que los
ciudadanos se le pregunten a un
organismo si tiene datos que le
pertenezcan en nombre de ese derecho de
accesos oes se puso en contacto con
Claire después se múltiples intentos
finalmente recibió cuatro fotos entre
las cuales Había una que nunca había
visto la foto la segunda foto es una
memoria de internet es una foto mía que
ya no está en línea pero que ellos
conservaron en su base de datos conocen
artículos en los que yo aparezco
retratada que ni siquiera yo sabía que
existían Entonces en ese momento decidí
ponerme en contacto con la Comisión
Nacional de informática y libertades
la Comisión Nacional de informática y
libertades es el organismo francés
encargado de aplicar el reglamento
general de protección de datos de la
Unión Europea
los datos biométricos tienen una
condición particular porque son datos
sensibles están relacionados con lo más
íntimo es decir el cuerpo la cara y su
tratamiento debe estar sujeto a
condiciones particulares básicamente
está prohibido utilizar los datos
biométricos de una persona salvo en
ciertas excepciones después de seis
meses la investigación la Comisión
Nacional de informática y libertades
acusó a Clear de haber violado el
reglamento europeo el alegato principal
es que habría recopilado datos
biométricos sin el consentimiento de los
interesados Aunque recibió un llamado
para borrar las fotografías de los
ciudadanos europeos no contestó
considera que el reglamento general de
protección de datos de la Unión Europea
no aplica para ella dice que no tiene CD
en Europa y que no ofrece sus servicios
a las empresas europeas el diálogo es
poco constructivo a finales de 2022 la
Comisión Nacional de informática y
libertades le impuso a la empresa
neoyorquina una multa de 20 millones de
euros
se negó a pagarla
[Música]
durante nuestro encuentro home se negó a
hablar sobre las preocupaciones europeas
nuestro equipo legal está encargando de
esas demandas lo único que les puedo
decir es que se trata de información
pública
en todas las redes sociales las cuentas
pueden ser públicas o privadas
Y si uno decide tener una Cuenta pública
Entonces es pública y las personas
pueden verla es como caminar por la
calle en público las personas pueden
tomarte una foto y después pueden usarla
[Música]
en el país de los gigantes tecnológicos
y de los magnates empresariales ninguna
Ley Federal protege los datos personales
ni regula el reconocimiento facial
el vacío jurídico es absoluto Hola estás
interesado en conocer acerca de la
tecnología de reconocimiento facial
en Times Square el departamento de
policía de Nueva York tiene ojos en
todas partes
ahí hay cuatro una dos tres cuatro cinco
seis siete son muchas y en lo alto de
los edificios hay más amnistía
internacional contabilizó 25.500 cámaras
del departamento de policía de Nueva
York en la ciudad sabemos que utilizan
la tecnología de reconocimiento facial
esas son sólo las que amnistía
internacional pudo identificar
dicen que esta tecnología está lejos de
ser infalible sobre todo cuando su
objetivo son las personas afro
tiende a identificar mal a las personas
entonces arrestan a la gente que no ha
hecho nada
hay casos en los que restan a las
personas con solo la prueba del
reconocimiento facial Sí hay muchos
un hombre en Nueva Jersey estuvo
detenido durante semanas solo por el
reconocimiento facial y nunca había
estado cerca de la escena del crimen
arrestaron a un hombre en Detroit solo
por reconocimiento facial y también fue
una coincidencia falsa
en todos esos casos de arresto se usa la
tecnología de reconocimiento facial
además ha habido muy pocos arrestos
injustos En comparación con la cantidad
general de casos que se han resuelto
para los activistas el reconocimiento
facial también supone una amenaza para
las libertades políticas
es la herramienta perfecta del
autoritarismo porque en una democracia
si uno permite que el gobierno sepa
dónde van las personas todo el tiempo
de repente desaparecen la libertad de
expresión la libertad de asociación la
libertad religiosa
La amenaza se concretó en 2020 la muerte
de George Floyd desató el movimiento
Black lives matter una serie de
protestas masivas en contra de las
violencias policiales los afroamericanos
Se tomaron las calles las
manifestaciones Se volvieron violentas
en varios estados la policía habría
utilizado el reconocimiento facial para
identificar a los manifestantes
la tecnología es tan poderosa y tan
proclive al abuso que no debería estar a
disposición de la policía y mucho menos
utilizarse para identificar a las
personas que participan en una protesta
ni aunque haya algún tipo de actividad
ilegal
si los manifestantes saben que corren el
riesgo de ser inmediatamente
identificados y rastreados por la
policía eso los va a disuadir de ejercer
su derecho constitucional a la protesta
[Música]
derick ingram presentó una denuncia
contra la policía de Nueva York la acusa
de haber utilizado el reconocimiento
facial para identificarlo y después para
intimidarlo
en mi caso y creo que se utilizó como un
arma yo lideraba gran parte del trabajo
activista que se estaba haciendo aquí en
la ciudad de Nueva York y creo que
estaban tratando de silenciarme
[Música]
ingram participó activamente en las
manifestaciones de 2020 hasta el punto
de ser buscado por la policía de Nueva
York
lo acusaban de haber dejado sordo a un
policía con un megáfono Tres semanas
después de ese señalamiento público
Derrick estaba en su casa cuando de
repente llegó la policía de Nueva York
empezó a las 7 de la mañana
había unos 30 policías rodeando mi casa
tenían arietes afuera de mi puerta
afuera había drones y cámaras en las
ventanas había francotiradores en lo
alto de los edificios
pensé que probablemente me matarían si
salía de mi apartamento
ese día la policía no tenía ninguna
orden de arresto refugiado en su
departamento Derrick pidió ayuda a
través de las redes sociales y los
activistas llegaron en masa
[Aplausos]
ante la presión la policía se retiró
derrite nunca fue acusado
todos los cargos se retiraron un año
después del incidente Y ahora yo
presenté una demanda contra el
departamento de policía de Nueva York
acusa a la policía de haber utilizado el
reconocimiento facial en su contra
durante la operación unos periodistas
captaron una imagen particular
en un documento policial se ve una foto
de derry la misma que la policía había
publicado en su señalamiento público
proviene de la cuenta de Instagram de
Derek
l creo que utilizaron las cámaras de
videovigilancia para después Buscar en
las redes sociales y encontrar
coincidencias con los vídeos que había
de ese día y una vez que lo hicieron
supieron exactamente dónde estaba Y
dónde vivía
en este correo electrónico enviado a un
periodista local el departamento de
policía de Nueva York confiesa haber
utilizado el reconocimiento facial para
esa investigación
no se hace ninguna precisión sobre el
programa que se usó Derrick sospecha que
fue pero no tiene pruebas
la policía de Nueva York nunca reconoció
haber utilizado
pero una ong accedió a dos años se
correspondencia entre la empresa y el
departamento de policía de Nueva York
cientos de Correos en los que se
demuestra que al menos hasta 2020 muchos
agentes habrían utilizado a sus anchas
la controvertida aplicación muchos están
firmados por Hong Kong
[Música]
otros están firmados por el cofundador
de clearview richards
[Música]
Richard schwards es un hombre discreto
en internet hay muy pocas fotos suyas
sin embargo ha jugado un papel muy
importante en Nueva York Durante los
años 1990 fue uno de los principales
asesores del alcalde rudolfo giuliani
giuliani fue el hombre que redujo el
crimen gracias a la política de
tolerancia cero e inauguró en Nueva York
La era de la videovigilancia
giuliana es abogado e íntimo amigo de
Donald Trump
welcome
richards no aceptó hablar con nosotros
según nuestras Fuentes fue gracias a sus
contactos que el departamento de policía
de Nueva York empezó a utilizar
afirma que gracias a él schwartz entró
en Club
Arce tiene muchas conexiones en toda
clase de círculos de derecha en Nueva
York saben en Nueva York realmente nada
avanza si no se cuenta con la ayuda de
un viejo judío en la denuncia que
presentó en marzo de 2023 Chuck afirma
que él mismo Hunter dadd y Richard
schwards fundaron juntos la empresa Pero
que a él lo traicionaron y lo apartaron
de Clear
entendí que querían quedarse con el
dinero que yo había conseguido y dejarme
a un lado Me parece que querían
deshacerse de mí que yo era un problema
para ellos
pero esa no es la versión de hongton
qué piensas sobre esas acusaciones son
ciertas no son ciertas mi socio richards
que es judío y yo fundamos la empresa y
lo hicimos para ayudar a las fuerzas de
seguridad al principio desarrollamos la
tecnología pero todo eso Simplemente no
es cierto
pero hizo negocios con Johnson conozco a
Charles Johnson pero no es el cofundador
de la empresa es un empleado no es un
miembro del Consejo no es un
inversionista y nunca lo ha sido Eso es
todo lo que diré al respecto
sí está mintiendo desafortunadamente es
triste ver a alguien mentir por dinero
es muy patético también es muy americano
de cierta manera quizás Ya se está
integrando
dos videos de la época en la que elijón
eran amigos aquí están en un campo de
tiro en California
aquí home aparece cantando una canción
sobre los trinos racistas
[Música]
en el grupo se escuchan comentarios
antisemitas
[Música]
encontramos otro video que había
desaparecido de internet una fiesta en
2016 en Nueva York miembros de los Boys
un grupo de extrema derecha
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y con ellos el director general de
comparte sus ideas políticas de ninguna
manera primero que todos no soy un
nacionalista blanco ni un supremacista
blanco ni siquiera Soy blanco
no es una empresa con motivaciones
políticas creo que ya terminamos
después de hacerle esas preguntas su
jefe de prensa nos amenazó si emitimos
esa parte de la entrevista nos
enfrentaríamos al abogado de clery
Artemisa la antigua activista de extrema
derecha también conoció a Job
un par de veces con supremacistas
blancos nunca lo vi por fuera de ese
círculo Aunque entiendo que ahora está
tratando de limpiar su reputación ante
el público
las raíces extremistas de Juan no se
reconocen y es muy inquietante
considerando que trabaja bajo contrato
con al menos seiscientos departamentos
de policía de Estados Unidos que tampoco
se hacen responsables
no cotiza en bolsa
y la composición de su capital no es
nada Clara
Jack pulson lleva tres años tratando de
resolver el misterio
en julio de 2021 se reportó que
estaba valorada en 130 millones de
dólares sería difícil decir cuál es su
valor actual pero probablemente no sea
más de 250 millones
su ong Investiga los vínculos entre las
empresas de tecnología y los organismos
de seguridad
[Música]
Jack encontró contratos entre Clear View
y el FBI el Ministerio de Justicia y el
de defensa
Hasta cierto punto en esos documentos
gubernamentales solo se ve la punta del
iceberg en cuanto al uso de programas de
vigilancia obviamente hizo un gran
esfuerzo por crear la relación para
poder venderle sus servicios
directamente a la policía en todo el
país y honestamente eso es mucho más
difícil de rastrear
lleva a cabo un cabildeo activo entre
los departamentos de policía locales la
empresa participó en muchos eventos en
nombre de la seguridad uno de ellos nos
llamó la atención la conferencia de
invierno de
sh se llevó a cabo en este hotel de
Washington
la prensa no está invitada
soy Jack pulson estoy en la conferencia
de invierno de la asociación de sheriffs
obtuvo una acreditación para entrar pero
está nervioso tratará de acercarse a
Clear ese día las excursiones a los
sheriffs giran en torno a las violencias
en la frontera mexicana
ya que está de incógnito Pero no por
mucho tiempo entra al espacio reservado
a las empresas privadas
y ahí está junto a axón una empresa que
fabrica pistolas eléctricas y cámaras
corporales
por ejemplo los empleados de Clear
escanean el rostro de Jack y lo
identifican rápidamente usaron el
reconocimiento facial conmigo y me
dijeron Quién era
es preocupante que alguien pueda
identificarte con tanta facilidad
preferiría que no me filmarás
ustedes pueden tomarme una foto y hacer
reconocimiento facial con ella pero yo
no puedo tomarle una foto a usted
deme sus datos por favor
estaba en una conferencia de policía la
verdad no quería que nadie conociera mi
identidad
me sentía expuesto tan solo hablando con
ellos
en un contrato de 1,5 millones de
dólares con el servicio de inmigración y
control de aduanas de Estados Unidos han
hecho miles de búsquedas muchas de ellas
llevadas a cabo por agentes que arrestan
y deportan inmigrantes indocumentados
empieza a buscar entre las redes
sociales del mundo entero y encuentra
una foto de un inmigrante en Estados
Unidos
la policía de fronteras podría tratar de
averiguar quién es esa persona
y si no quieren que se convierta en un
ciudadano la podrían deportar
en uno de los contratos entre y la
policía de fronteras Jack encontró la
siguiente frase
Las ovejas odian al perro pastor hasta
que están rodeadas por lobos
[Música]
esa terminología de ovejas perros
pastores y lobos es común entre los
círculos nacionalistas en Estados Unidos
lo que quieren decir con esa frase es
que se puede criticar lo que hace la
policía de fronteras o Claire View hasta
que un lobo es decir
un criminal te ataca Y entonces regresas
corriendo a donde los perros pastores
[Música]
California prohibió que su policía
utilizara el recono
[Música]
cimiento
pero las agencias federales como la
policía de fronteras si tienen derecho a
usarlo
[Música]
crecer indocumentadas significa tener
que resolver constantemente como vivir
Cómo llegar a fin de mes
Cómo hacer para estudiar Cómo conseguir
un trabajo simplemente Cómo tener una
vida aquí
Mi nombre es Reina tengo 29 años soy
dueña de un negocio aquí en California
reina Maldonado se mudó de México a
Estados Unidos con su madre cuando tenía
6 años ahora es dueña de un restaurante
presentó una demanda conjunta en contra
dewei desde su adolescencia ha luchado
por los derechos de los trabajadores
inmigrantes
fue de una acción que tuvimos en el 2013
para llamar la atención las
deportaciones que estaban pasando
durante la administración de Obama antes
reina no dudaba en publicar ese tipo de
videos en las redes sociales pero desde
que se enteró de la existencia de
prefiere mantener un bajo perfil
dejé de utilizar Facebook comparto muy
poco en Instagram y tampoco estoy activa
en Twitter
so many
muchos aspectos de mi vida cambiaron
cuando entendí cómo funciona clip View
eye
la demanda en la que participó reina
denuncia que la tecnología de vigilancia
de Clear viey violaría los derechos de
privacidad y facilitaría que el gobierno
monitorea manifestantes inmigrantes y
comunidades afro ves
tiene un efecto paralizante para los
activistas porque es una manera de
controlar y manipular Cómo puede
funcionar una sociedad
quieren intimidarnos quieren asustarnos
quieren venderle nuestros datos a
personas que tienen el control y que
pueden usarlos en nuestra contra
el mercado Mundial de la vigilancia vale
cientos de miles de millones de dólares
Hoy se celebra en Nueva York la
conferencia internacional de seguridad
se presentan las últimas innovaciones en
el sector
[Música]
está mirando el vino toma una botella y
la mete en su bolso
acabamos de solucionar ese problema en
unos cuantos segundos también
[Música]
aprovechamos para hacerle unas preguntas
Hola cómo está Cómo van los negocios Muy
bien gracias Cuántas imágenes tiene
ahora en su base de datos Ahora son 30
mil millones 30.000 millones
Y cómo va su proyecto de tener la cara
de todas las personas del mundo
sabe cada foto es una pista que puede
ayudarnos a resolver un crimen pero aquí
no estamos dando entrevistas por qué
está molesto
queríamos hablar sobre sus clientes
extranjeros Y si hablamos sobre el uso
que hace Ucrania de su tecnología
bueno
[Música]
en Ucrania pero también en el Golfo
Pérsico a finales de 2022 durante un
juicio en Londres el abogado de Clear
reveló que la aplicación también se
usaba en emiratos árabes Unidos
[Música]
un pequeño país muy rico gracias a sus
reservas de gas tiene 9 millones de
habitantes de los cuales 8 millones son
extranjeros están ahí solo para trabajar
y nunca obtendrán la nacionalidad el
régimen es una monarquía absoluta aliada
a occidente nadie se atreve a criticar a
la familia del poder
las personas tienden a pensar que en
emiratos árabes Unidos hay una especie
de gobierno masivo y represivo lo dicen
porque no han ido nunca
Simplemente no es una democracia insisto
en eso no todos los países tienen que
ser una democracia
emiratos árabes Unidos gasta millones de
dólares cada año en Estados Unidos para
blanquear su reputación no quieren que
pensemos en los abusos de Derechos
Humanos que cometen ahí no quieren que
pensemos en las detenciones ilegales de
académicos extranjeros que ocurren ahí
solo quieren que pensemos en Fly
emirates y en todas las cosas buenas que
tiene el país
No creo que emiratos árabes Unidos sea
otra cosa más que una fuerza de
estabilidad paz y progreso
emiratos árabes Unidos es un cliente
importante para las empresas de armas
occidentales
hoy en abu dhabi la feria internacional
de defensa está en pleno auge hay
grandes contratos en juego
desde 2020 el país tiene un nuevo Aliado
de peso el estado de Israel pionero en
materia de reconocimiento facial
[Aplausos]
ambos países se establecieron una
alianza estratégica en contra de su
enemigo común la República islámica de
Irán
[Música]
estamos muy orgullosos de estar aquí
gracias a los acuerdos de Abraham
y nos sentimos muy seguros las
autoridades son muy amables
emiratos árabes Unidos ha incrementado
Los acuerdos de cooperación tecnológica
con Israel
ahora está a la vanguardia en materia de
Inteligencia artificial y de
reconocimiento facial
[Música]
con el reconocimiento facial se puede
encontrar a cualquier persona en
cualquier parte
National
el reconocimiento facial se ha vuelto
parte de la cotidianidad en emiratos
árabes Unidos emiratos árabes es como el
gran hermano tratan de controlarlo todo
dentro del país
yo lo llamo La jaula de oro
de Derechos Humanos huyó del país en
2012 por haber exigido reformas corría
el riesgo de ser encarcelado
en el país hay cámaras en todas partes
en cada calle
vigilan a todo el mundo eso genera una
especie de miedo entre la población
[Música]
tienen un sistema llamado falcon eye lo
usan para espiar a todo el mundo
por todo el país hay cámaras instaladas
a lo largo de las carreteras y en los
edificios permitiendo que las
autoridades vigilan a las personas todo
el tiempo este sistema de vigilancia se
llama falconái el ojo del Halcón
tenemos todo autorizado para monitorear
las infracciones de los conductores las
personas reciben un mensaje en su móvil
de forma casi instantánea para avisarles
que van demasiado rápido o que están
hablando por teléfono no es un sistema
para controlar a la comunidad sino para
facilitarnos la vida a todos no se sabe
exactamente Qué órganos el gobierno
utilizan las autoridades no contestaron
a nuestras preguntas en Londres el
abogado de Crew simplemente habló de
Dubai la capital económica es difícil
verificarlo pero en este video la
policía local de dubái muestra su gusto
por los dispositivos del futuro
[Música]
no me parecería un problema que hay le
venda a Dubai depende de cómo lo
utilicen Si la policía de Dubai lo
utiliza de la misma manera como lo hace
la policía de Estados Unidos no habría
ningún problema
Freeman considera que Richard Clark no
es totalmente objetivo cuando habla de
emiratos árabes Unidos Clark tiene
vínculos cercanos con las autoridades
emiratíes algunos lo acusan de hacer
lobby para el país pero él lo niega
rotundamente Richard Clark es el
fundador de good Harbor consulting una
consultora que trabaja mucho en emiratos
árabes Unidos y que incluso les ha
ayudado a crear el sistema de vigilancia
que tienen pensemos que es una parte
clave de las operaciones de influencia
de emiratos árabes Unidos Aquí en
Estados Unidos y posiblemente también en
el extranjero según Clark cute Harbor no
se dedica a hacer lobby sino que es una
empresa consultora en ciberseguridad que
solo trabaja con clientes el sector
privado y solo opera en Estados Unidos
de hecho uno de los primeros
occidentales en haberlos ayudado es
Richard Clark
en 2019 la agencia routers reveló que a
finales de los 2000 Clark había ayudado
a emiratos árabes Unidos a crear una
unidad especial de espionaje su objetivo
inicial era rastrear terroristas pero
terminaron concentrándose en periodistas
y disidentes
es el gran Arquitecto de la dimensión
tecnológica de la agencia nacional de
seguridad posterior a los atentados del
11 de septiembre y desde el 2005 pensó
que podría ganar más dinero en el sector
privado entonces empezó a trabajar para
los emiratos árabes creando Algo similar
para ellos
las herramientas de vigilancia masiva
que se pensaba existían solo en China
han llegado hasta los emiratos árabes
Unidos el presidente Mohamed vinsaye es
un fanático de la Inteligencia
artificial
[Música]
le gustaría utilizar la tecnología para
controlarlo todo para saberlo todo
desde la primavera árabe el objetivo
principal del ciber ejército emiratí ya
no es la lucha contra el terrorismo o al
qaeda ahora su objetivo es acabar con la
democracia en el mundo árabe eliminando
a los disidentes en su propio país o
incluso en el extranjero
nuestra inclusión en los emiratos nos
recordó este trineo de hongton Dad
publicado en 2015 después de la
primavera árabe
no nos quedaremos callados Seguiremos
luchando nuestra comunidad no se quedará
en silencio dejando que vendan nuestros
datos biométricos a una base de datos
mientras los derechos reproductivos se
ven amenazados en Estados Unidos algunas
mujeres temen que el reconocimiento
facial se utilice para identificarlas
mucha gente se preocupa ante la
posibilidad de que la Inteligencia
artificial sea usada como una
herramienta de control
el reconocimiento facial y las cámaras
de vigilancia podrían usarse para
controlar a las mujeres
las mujeres que van a una clínica de
aborto temen ser identificadas incluso
Aunque lleven puesta una máscara o un
velo la tecnología las puede identificar
es muy preocupante lo rápido que está
evolucionando
ha leído 1984 le di 35 páginas del libro
pero creo que ahora vivimos en un mundo
muy distinto del de 1984
[Música]
no está tan seguro le preocupa un
programa de búsqueda del FBI y del
pentágono que podría servir para
identificar en tiempo real a los
ciudadanos estadounidenses con cámaras y
drones
tenemos muchas preocupaciones sobre el
uso de la tecnología de reconocimiento
facial Pero esto es realmente una
pesadilla empieza a parecerse a lo que
está pasando en algunas sociedades
totalitarias
las personas que están haciendo lo
correcto no tienen nada de que
preocuparse
pero son tiempos difíciles para
la empresa debe decenas de millones de
euros de multa a países extranjeros Y
todavía tiene procesos abiertos en
Estados Unidos en lugares como Nueva
Jersey y en otras jurisdicciones se ha
prohibido que la policía utilice Clear
View esos debates deben continuar
viaja con frecuencia Ucrania ha
mencionado la posibilidad de abrir una
oficina en el país en guerra
por su parte Chuck jura que no es
racista incluso dice que apoya al actual
presidente demócrata Joe biden mire el
ángulo de la nariz creo que en francés
se dice niacuilán lo que me interesa es
el futuro es el uso de la genética para
predecir el rostro pero todavía estamos
muy lejos de eso mientras Espera que se
resuelva el proceso contra
nuevos proyectos siempre en el ámbito de
la biométrica he invertido en varias
empresas de ADN y estamos creando una
base de datos genéticos muy grande
quiero que eventualmente Estados Unidos
y muchos otros gobiernos tendrán un
registro del ADN de todo el mundo nacía
siempre ha estado interesada en la
biométrica al cabo de nuestra
investigación varias preguntas han
quedado sin respuesta en particular la
de posibles vínculos entre Blue eye y la
más secreta de las agencias
estadounidenses contactamos a la Cia
para tratar de averiguarlo
diez días después nos llamó una mujer
que decía trabajar en la agencia
pero la Cia utiliza tecnología de
reconocimiento facial
[Música]
tecnologías como las que acabamos de ver
en reporteros Plus ponen muchas
preguntas sobre la mesa respecto al
reconocimiento facial y a los posibles
riesgos que enfrenta la privacidad Cómo
ponerle límites a esta clase de
Inteligencia artificial y garantizar su
uso ético Cuáles son los riesgos de que
se almacene tanta información Privada de
las personas para conversar y debatir
sobre este tema nos acompaña desde
Buenos Aires Freddy vivas ingenieros y
fundador de rock in Data una compañía
que trabaja con la ciencia de datos para
hacerla más accesible en Ciudad de
México está Raúl Monroy líder del grupo
de investigación en Inteligencia
artificial avanzada del tecnológico de
Monterrey y ex presidente de la sociedad
mexicana de Inteligencia artificial a
ellos les doy la bienvenida a este
debate Gracias por estar con nosotros y
Freddy quiero comenzar por ustedes
estábamos viendo en el programa anterior
son las potencialidades y también los
riesgos de formatos como Clear View
Francia por ejemplo lo prohibió en 2021
diciendo que era una violación a los
derechos de la privacidad y que estas
imágenes se recolectaban de sitios
públicos como Facebook Instagram
etcétera sin el consentimiento de las
personas La pregunta es son datos
privados sabiendo que están en redes
públicas
bueno Primero gracias por la invitación
realmente es un debate increíble y y la
verdad que hay mucho para discutir y
mucho para pensar estas tecnologías como
la Inteligencia artificial
específicamente la visión artificial
abre un debate gigante sobre la
privacidad de los datos tal cual lo
estás mencionando nosotros en Buenos
Aires en Argentina tuvimos algunas
situaciones parecidas ahora no se está
utilizando esta tecnología
se abrió de alguna forma un debate sobre
la ética y se hicieron grandes
conversaciones en los últimos dos o tres
años te diría que terminaron en una
recomendación que Se generó y salió esta
semana Incluso
en Argentina como una recomendación de
alguna forma inspirada también en
prácticas como la recomendación ética
responsable de la UNESCO que salió el
año pasado UNESCO salió a contarnos una
investigación que hizo durante dos años
sobre cómo incorporar estas tecnologías
tan potentes y que pueden derivar en
usos muy positivos para la sociedad Pero
cómo la encaramos desde un punto de
vista ético hasta dónde llegamos la
UNESCO con este marco de recomendación
investigó durante dos años en 150 países
y y este marco érico arrojó buenas
buenos insights respecto al uso correcto
sin duda todavía no tenemos como ustedes
lo saben en Europa una una ley que pueda
ponerse digamos en ejecución donde
nosotros podamos tener un marco
regulatorio para todo para todo el
continente sin duda el GP piar es una de
las prácticas que nosotros desde
latinoamérica miramos con detalle porque
nos parece una buena inspiración pero
todavía no estamos
no tenemos una garantía ni un marco para
seguir paso a paso de cómo implementar
la ciencia de datos y la inteligencia
artificial nosotros siempre tenemos una
mirada de desde Rock in Data
interna con un equipo de ética tenemos
dos filósofos trabajando en eso tenemos
siempre la mirada desde los sesgos y
Cómo evitarlos y cómo disminuirlos pero
la realidad es que todavía no hay una
cosa sobre piedra podríamos decir que
regule todas estas cuestiones que
estamos conversando No claro y
precisamente es uno de los grandes
vacíos de la Inteligencia artificial
actualmente Y es que no existen
principios que puedan limitar su alcance
y hacer de esta siempre y siempre una
práctica ética Le quiero preguntar al
respecto a Raúl Monroy Gracias por
acompañarnos cuéntenos desde la creación
de la Inteligencia artificial sobre todo
la que tiene que ver con reconocimiento
facial Cómo se puede garantizar la
protección a la privacidad Y si también
de paso nos puede hablar de qué
significa el aprendizaje profundo y las
redes neuronales de estos sistemas que
son los que permiten recolectar datos
para que luego la Inteligencia
artificial los utilice un solo un
ejemplo la red neuronal por ejemplo es
lo que utilizan programas como Siri o
Alexa en este sentido Cómo funcionan y
también cómo garantizar desde su
creación y su funcionamiento las
prácticas éticas
si hay varios aspectos que uno puede
discutir al respecto en principio hay
una corriente muy fuerte en el mundo de
hacer una guía responsable Cómo llegar a
esto es algo que aún no sabemos Yo
entiendo que hay esfuerzos Incluso en
esta semana en México en la Universidad
Nacional Autónoma Autónoma de México
hubo un evento en relación con el Cómo
empezar a juntar a todos los actores
para regular
pues las diversas implicaciones
injerencias que puede tener la
Inteligencia artificial en la sociedad
mi opinión llegar a una ética a una
Inteligencia artificial responsable si
demanda necesariamente de la unión
esfuerzo de todos los actores incluyendo
evidentemente
gobierno porque todo esto debe
traducirse en políticas públicas debe
incluir a la academia para ver de qué
manera desde
el mismo diseño así como podemos hacer
código seguro podemos hacer código
responsable
Cuando esto podrá ser posible No lo sé
pero pero creo que esa sería la
dirección en la que tendríamos que
trabajar y es una dirección a la que ya
hemos llamado desde hace ya Algunos años
en la ONU se han presentado colegas
entre ellos Toby Walls quienes han están
llamado la atención sobre el desarrollo
de armas autónomas y su implicación
verdad desde el punto de vista ético y
moral ahora bien en relación al
aprendizaje profundo redes neuronales De
nada más decir Bueno una red neuronal No
es otra cosa más que pues un sistema
físico que es capaz de
autorregular una serie de pesos para
producir o para reducir una tarea de
predicción a unos y ceros o en todo caso
a una serie de pesos pero que al final
verdad se colecta en una salida y que
dice si si lo que me estás diciendo
existe o no existe eso puede hacerse en
una imagen o en cualquier otro tipo de
señal siempre y cuando sea traducida a
un formato Pues que la máquina pueda
procesar
las redes normales se inventaron desde
hace ya muchísimos años solamente que
hasta hace poco no había sido posible
correr estas redes neuronales en
arquitecturas que le llamamos profundas
es decir
redes neuronales que reinectar unas
cuantas neuronas interrumpenten miles
millones de neuronas Entonces eso es lo
que hace o probó produce el aprendizaje
profundo y este aprendizaje profundo es
el digamos lo que ha traído nuevamente a
la Inteligencia artificial en la
sociedad
Perdón adelante usted
explica un poco Cómo funciona la
Inteligencia artificial Cómo se
recolecta la información para que el
mecanismo pueda convertirlo en unos y
ceros es decir en algoritmos para poder
perfeccionar su búsqueda en las redes y
en internet yo le quiero preguntar a
Freddy y es bueno tenemos un vacío en
este momento sobre esa regulación esos
principios como bien ustedes dos lo
señalaron Mi pregunta es en este momento
programas como Clear View y otros están
haciendo reconocimiento facial masivo lo
almacenan sin tener un límite de tiempo
de guardar esas imágenes y luego lo
están vendiendo a gobiernos a
instituciones a empresas etcétera Cómo
se regula hoy por hoy Esto ante el vacío
de Estos principios éticos
Bueno hay varias miradas sobre este tipo
de casos no es el primero que vemos
hemos visto a lo largo de los años
diferentes situaciones similares donde
uno se descarga una aplicación uno
accede un sistema que tiene un propósito
aparente donde nosotros muchas veces
somos el producto digamos no muchas
veces no pagamos por el acceso a alguna
determinada herramienta y justamente
porque no estamos pagando lo que está
pasando por detrás es que hay un negocio
hay un modelo de negocio que utiliza los
datos como la mercancía Y en muchos
casos lo que hacen es vender insights
como servicio o sea muchas veces somos
parte de un grupo de un segmento
específico que por ejemplo nos gusta
hacer determinada acción compramos
determinado tipo de producto vivimos en
una determinada zona entramos en una
caracterización de usuario y eso muchas
veces las empresas pagan para acceder a
bases de datos
que puede ser que sean agrupadas puede
ser que sean anonimizadas puede ser que
sean datos encriptados y que nuestra
vida privada no sea afectado por esto
eso sería el mejor escenario el peor
escenario es que bueno las empresas
comercializan nuestros datos privados
nuestros datos personales nuestro
nuestra intimidad nuestros gustos
o nuestra nuestra visión a nivel por
ejemplo político electoral no O nuestras
elecciones psicológicas incluso sexuales
como ha pasado durante los años entonces
creo que dada esa complejidad de posible
manipulación de nuestros datos para
intentar convencernos de votar a alguien
o comprar un producto o hacer
determinada acción esto debe ser sin
duda
observado como en profundidad hay
también digamos no solo los datos que
uno cede cuando pone completa
información sino también están los datos
que pueden ser inferidos por ejemplo si
yo compro comida la aplicación y elijo
comprar productos sin gluten por ejemplo
sin lactosa la aplicación de alguna
forma puede inferir que yo sea alérgico
a determinadas comidas entonces podría
vender mi información
para que una empresa que fabrica un
determinado producto me tenga dentro de
su base de datos bueno todas esas
cuestiones pasan el tema muchas veces es
que no hay transparencia de cómo se hace
eso y tampoco
muchas veces hay conciencia de parte del
usuario por lo tanto creo que hay tres
grandes actores que estamos hablando de
las legislaciones los estados los
usuarios nosotros Cuál es nuestra
responsabilidad sobre lo que tenemos que
saber la ciudadanía digital A qué le
damos acceso a que no y las empresas que
van a tener que hacer más transparentes
y comunicar más de lo que de lo que
hacen con nuestra información no sin
embargo aquí ya estamos en otro paso más
adelante distinto a que las compañías
sepan en nuestros gustos nuestras
preferencias nuestras incluso políticas
o nuestra edad porque ya estamos
hablando de nuestras propias imágenes de
las imágenes de nuestros rostros en una
era en la que la Inteligencia artificial
a través por ejemplo del Deep fake Puede
crear vídeos que son absolutamente
falsos con nuestra cara con nuestro tono
de voz como si fuéramos nosotros quienes
grabáramos esos vídeos Y ahora esta
información puede estar en manos de
privados Raúl En ese sentido Cómo
garantizar la la protección de nuestros
datos privados sobre todo evitar que
hackers puedan infiltrarse en compañías
de Inteligencia artificial
es la pregunta del del millón mira en
realidad yo creo que lo más importante
aquí es que a final de cuentas todo lo
que está en internet todo lo que puedes
ver a través de una computadora pues no
crees No debes creer necesariamente en
el No todo lo que escuches a través de
una computadora No necesariamente debes
creerme efectivamente como como acabas
de decir podemos
recientemente de hecho salieron
al público fotos del papa este vistiendo
chamarras y quizás ni existen o a restos
de Donald Trump etcétera lo cierto Es
que todas esas cuestiones o todas esas
fotos o imágenes no eran realmente fotos
no eran fotos que estuvieron captando
una situación real
lo que tenemos que hacer es empezar a
educar a la gente por un lado a a tener
esta crítica acerca de lo que recibe y
no creer completamente en todo lo que
aparece de manera pública en los en
particular a través de este contenido no
Y la otra es que Bueno definitivamente
si eres parte de una red social estás
en algunos casos incluso aceptando que
el riesgo de que usen tus fotos no
solamente
con estos cines verdad de producir un
video
en donde tú haces algo que no no no no
no es cierto pero también puede ser que
que lo usen con razones como lo decía
Freddy no Para perfilarte tomar en mayor
información del público etcétera no
Entonces es muy complicado es muy muy
complicado la pregunta que me hace
quiero enfatizar Precisamente en ese
lado porque usted habla uno que hacer
nosotros como consumidores de
información y tener ciertos límites y
ciertos filtros para entender que no
todo es cierto pero del lado de los
usuarios a los cuales se les toman las
imágenes Le quiero preguntar a Freddy
qué pueden hacer No sé los usuarios de
distintas redes sociales para evitar que
sus imágenes sus fotografías terminen
haciendo parte de una base de datos de
reconocimiento facial perdimos la
conexión por el momento Con Freddy Le
quiero preguntar a Raúl
Sí bueno como decía yo en algunas redes
sociales una vez que uno Abre una cuenta
acepta la posibilidad de que sus fotos
las fotos que uno sube el contenido
incluso verdad que uno genera sea
propiedad de la empresa o de que maneja
la red social eso es algo que nosotros
debemos estar conscientes Aunque tenemos
algunas maneras de configurar la la
privacidad o a quienes en el público
llega la información que nosotros
generamos nada detiene a las empresas
detrás de estas redes sociales de usar
nuestras nuestros contenidos
sea texto gráfico para realizar
cualquier cosa para las cuales
desconocemos no la falta de
transferencia y la falta de
verificabilidad hacen de esto algo muy
complicado entonces
no podemos detenerlo excepto que
nosotros mismos detengamos este tipo de
publicación
ahora el asunto es cómo están estos
modelos de negocio A quiénes se venden
esta información es algo que como decía
Freddy debemos transparentar o las
compañías lo interrumpo hay un segundo
qué tanta qué tanta trazabilidad tenemos
precisamente de esos negocios de venta
de bases de datos a compañías
no no existe hasta donde yo tengo
entendido no existe porque al final de
cuentas las fotografías que uno puede
poner una red social y que se venden
verdad me pueden estar completamente
escondidas o completamente en el mercado
negro
Bueno quiero regresar Entonces Con
Freddy es un debate bastante complejo y
que nos deja panoramas poco
esperanzadores y la pregunta que voy a
hacer quizás deje menos esperanza y es
que en marzo de 2023 El Instituto Future
of Life que promueve el uso de
Inteligencia artificial bajo rigores
éticos hizo una carta a la que también
se sumaron por ejemplo personajes tan
tan importantes en el mundo de la
tecnología como elon musk que es el ceo
de Twitter y también Steve Bosnia que el
cofundador de Apple ellos y decenas de
investigadores y de líderes tecnológicos
más dijeron que era necesario frenar el
desarrollo de la Inteligencia artificial
que fuera superior al chat gpt 4 hasta
seis meses mientras se tenía un rigor
completo de que lo que se estaba
produciendo y que la Inteligencia
artificial que se estaba creando
actualmente no iba a superar las
capacidades humanas y afirmaron tiene
que desarrollarse solamente una vez
estemos seguros de que sus efectos serán
positivos y llamaron también a
desarrollar un protocolo de seguridad
que además pudiera ser verificado por
otra entidad precisamente para proteger
esos datos Y para limitar y tener los
principios éticos completos de la
Inteligencia artificial Freddy usted qué
tan lejos cree que estamos de tener
estos protocolos y de garantizar que
estamos seguros de que los efectos de la
Inteligencia artificial no serán nocivos
para la humanidad
bueno hace poco salió también un informe
del foro económico mundial hablando de
esto del impacto en el trabajo
específicamente de la Inteligencia
artificial en ese informe que es uno de
los más concretos que tenemos
arroja que aproximadamente un 23% de los
trabajos del mundo van a estar
fuertemente impactados por la
Inteligencia artificial esto significa
que algunos de esos trabajos podrían
desaparecer o transformarse muchísimo a
través de esta tecnología sin duda
estamos viviendo una Revolución
Industrial basada en la economía del
conocimiento y la Inteligencia
artificial está siendo
esto real digamos la Inteligencia
artificial y esta carta donde también
hay otros comentarios como los que hizo
arar y
sin duda nos trae una reflexión cuando
sale una Innovación tan poderosa y se
lanza al mercado recordemos que chat gpt
tiene desde salir noviembre 2022 y
adquirió usuarios en cinco días es lo
más rápido que se popularizó como a
nivel aplicación a nivel herramienta de
software las siguientes Instagram con
dos meses y medio y Netflix tres años y
medio o sea es tremenda el impacto la
democratización es la primera
herramienta de Inteligencia artificial
que se pone en manos de tantas personas
tan rápido eso es muy difícil de seguir
el ritmo de esa Innovación por lo tanto
esto de crear un organismo global que
pueda de alguna forma Estar mirando
estar auditando yo creo que es algo que
va a tener que suceder no sé si estamos
cerca de eso probablemente tengamos un
año más por lo menos hasta esa
definición yo creo que los algoritmos
hoy
van a empezar a buscar la transparencia
dejar de ser una caja negra y empezar a
hacer una caja transparente no una caja
de vidrio nosotros podamos entender cómo
decide un algoritmo sobre lo que nos
está mostrando ya sea una recomendación
de la película La aprobación de un
crédito un texto generado
No creo que corran riesgo nuestro
trabajo como mucha gente está saliendo a
decir
pero sí que va a incidir fuertemente no
ellos cuando dicen seis meses se
refieren seis meses frenar la
Inteligencia artificial generativa no la
Inteligencia artificial
y lo que usted menciona es sumamente
importante porque quizás la humanidad
esté frente a la mayor Revolución
tecnológica que ha habido después del
internet en este sentido ya para ir
cerrando nuestro programa Le quiero
preguntar
a Ramón a Raúl si es Cómo ve usted la
relación entre privacidad e Inteligencia
artificial está garantizada nuestra
privacidad en la era que se nos viene
bueno a ver podemos usar Inteligencia
artificial para muchos propósitos y uno
de ellos pues puede ser simplemente
construir algo que
pues te manipule o más bien te
influencie te influye influye en
en tu decisión de darme datos que tú
consideras privados posiblemente te
estoy diciendo que está ocurriendo algo
muy difícil usar algunas técnicas que
usan los vendedores de que no pierdas
esta oportunidad única y te puedo
convencer seguramente a través de una
máquina de que reveles datos que no
debieras hacerlo no eso es un hecho
entonces
La verdad es que la Inteligencia
artificial por lo menos conocemos la la
generativa como se refiere Freddy Chad
te puede usarse para diferentes cosas
diferentes fines
Pero dentro de estos Bueno siempre puede
encontrarle a alguien alguno que no sea
cómodo bueno positivo y demás por
ejemplo
le pido que vaya redondeando la idea que
se nos acaba el tiempo sí Bueno
básicamente Yo creo que es muy
importante la participación de la gente
en
el entender siempre y estar alerta
verdad hacia Con quién está
interactuando pero dado que tenemos
estas cosas tan avanzadas pues es muy
importante eso Freddy vivas muy
brevemente Cuál es su conclusión
mi conclusión está muy relacionada lo
que dice Raúl para mí hay que
desarrollar la ciudadanía digital O sea
que todos los usuarios estamos en
internet tenemos que entender que
cedemos a qué le decimos que sí A qué
leemos que decimos que no no podemos
esperar solamente reglamentaciones
globales sino que tenemos que tener esa
responsabilidad y nuestro trabajo
también como divulgadores es hacer que
eso sea una cosa cotidiana no y planes
educativos para desarrollar este tipo de
conocimiento como lo hicimos con la
ciudadanía como cualquier persona del
mundo creo que eso es lo más importante
educación entonces Freddy vivas y Raúl
Monroy Gracias por acompañarnos y a
ustedes gracias por estar aquí en France
24 la producción de este programa estuvo
a cargo de Luis Fernando Montes y la de
los invitados con Tania Herrera sigan
con nosotros
[Música]